là tout de suite a comme ça c'est pas
pris ça serait bien
et tant pis si j'étais là je me suis dit
ça
au passage elle
balade vous présente le cas médical est
le promoteur alors
présentez-vous les uns après les autres
commence par toi
bah
ouais ouais dommage mais les idoles qui
est qu'il ait pas fait ce métier serait
dictateur dans son pays c'est sûr je
pense que je suis du tramway samedi
ouais on avait besoin d'une blanche
alors on la fait rire bon ça m'a bien
jouer tu t'appelles comment blanches ail
blanc
hamel enfin fabrice patson jahl d'edo
qui boit litre de sang humain par jour
et jamy dit le comte de bouderbala
on peut vous aurez le privilège de
retrouver cet été sur canal + j'espère
vous serez nombreux à regarder cette
émission a vaut le coup
[Musique]